hey everybody welcome back to four vara
and welcome back to what should
hopefully be the last episode of this
series but then again I think that's
also when I said about the episode
before this and there will most likely
probably be another episode after this
but in any case I'm really trying to
finish this all up and get to a stage
where I feel like it's good enough to
make a final video out of it but you
know where exactly that whole process is
going to end I'm honestly not really
sure I was just hoping that at the end
of this episode I would feel dumb enough
to call it a day and work on some final
video for the project but in the end
that didn't really end up happening so
what I'm doing in this episode is most
of all all of the lighting throughout
the island it is at some point that I
decided to switch the game to night mode
that I realized that the park is
actually really underwhelming at nights
since I didn't really think about
lighting beforehand and a few lights
that are in the park here and there
don't really help to line it up in a
nice way so I decided to finally take it
upon me to add all the lights to the
island and make sure that I can also
show this off at night or when I upload
the park fire you can actually look at
the coaster at night as well
I think that should look quite nice in
any case I want to give a huge thanks to
Gertz from shyguys world who posted a
tutorial on the planets posted forums as
well a very long time ago already so at
the time we didn't really have that many
lights but it's still an amazing
tutorial he basically posted a tutorial
of what to do with the different lights
in planet coaster and how to
realistically light a theme park and
there's lots of useful tips in there the
focus of the tutorial is mostly
realistic lighting so I'm definitely
gonna deviate a little bit from it
heading in quite a few places since this
project is all but realistic really but
the the ideas of how to use lights and
how you can use the specific lights
in-game I think are still very much
relevant here and one of the things
which I always think
is very interesting and noteworthy about
that tutorial
is the focus on selecting things that
you want in lights and of course at the
same time selecting things that you
don't really feel like lighting as he
stated in the tutorial and in something
which you can have literally see quite a
bit a very common mistake that people
make when they're lighting something is
to just kind of light it all up and
consider the job done when everything is
visible even at nights because it's
properly lit instead of choosing certain
elements that are most important or most
striking about a certain building and
lighting those while keeping other
elements of it perhaps somewhat darker
or completely unlit and I wanted to line
up most of the island since it's kind of
floating in the middle of nothing and I
would like it to stick out quite a bit
but there are some corners which I don't
really end up lighting and most of the
sort of methodology for me to light
everything was to think about the the
most detailed and the most signature
sort of looking parts of the build and
try to light those first so there's
gonna be a lot of focus on lighting the
different spires and elements like that
throughout the build and then there's a
little bit of work with color as well
although not too much I'm mostly just
kind of using very muted Brown and
orange and red ish colors very similar
to the color scheme of the island itself
and I find when you're doing lighting in
planet coaster at least for me I always
like to make the colors a little bit
darker and a bit more black to them so
they're a little bit more washed out
because very often going for completely
white or for completely colored lights
in planet coaster might end you up with
some super bright lights and then some
super dark areas that really clash with
that a little bit too much so I always
like to make it at least somewhat muted
and then I also try to use some sort of
similar lights as well for similar areas
so for some of these spires for instance
that whole plan over there didn't really
work
so well but for some of these fires I'm
going with some of the more brights
orange and red ish used mostly and then
all of the the wall sections have a very
similar sort of orange hue to them and
then the lowest parts of the island have
a sort of more reddish tone to the
lighting it's something which probably
doesn't make much sense as I'm saying it
right now but hopefully as we go through
the episode it should make a little bit
more sense eventually so yeah this it's
very sort of easy and simple thing to do
I'm just going around the island seeing
the areas that aren't entirely lits and
seeing what kind of lights would work
best so for instance here's the other
side of the island and I didn't want to
light up the bottom of the island but I
didn't want to slightly add some lights
to the the parts where the buildings on
the top of the island sort of change
into the bottom parts and put some sort
of red lights here and there in that
section to kind of very mildly light it
up and kind of kind of show a little bit
of the pipes and crazy like machinery
stuff that is going on in the band the
bottom of the island but not too much
it's not really the focus it's just kind
of showing that there's not nothing over
there and then for most of the the
lighting it's just kind of putting
lights around all of these towers and
domes and spires etc and also lining up
quite a few of the windows very often
what's just very easy and fun thing to
do is to just put some spotlights on
windows and doors and that sort of thing
and what I found actually very often in
real life if you have very classical
looking buildings with lots of pillars
very often the lights that light the
buildings are placed on these pillars so
the pillars are lit up the most that's
also something that I try to do quite a
bit and then there's other areas like
this as well like the path where I just
wanted to have regular sort of street
lights this is a really difficult
episode to actually put a commentary
over I think since it's just really kind
of all over the place the the real
strategy is just to go around seeing
what's not
let live yet and putting some lights
there that's really all there is to it
it's not too much to say about it I got
to be completely honest also I am
recording this way late at night so I'm
trying my deck tennis not to fall asleep
at the moment as well so I'm sorry if
it's not the absolute best commentary
ever maybe I'll just have to venture a
little bit more interpersonal territory
which is something I never do because
I'm that kind of boring youtuber I guess
it just talks exclusively about what I'm
doing in the game and never reveals
anything about their lives outside of
that but um yeah maybe I should do that
a little bit more because eventually I'm
gonna run out of things to say about
lights to be honest though I'm already
sometimes kind of impressed by how long
I manage to talk about completely stupid
things and keep meandering on and on
about certain topics and actually have
people listening as well I feel like at
some points my my commentaries must just
feel like I'm trying to reach the word
counts on an essay honestly which yes
isn't too much of a compliment to give
myself but I think that's the way I
mostly am able to keep talking for long
periods of time without actually having
to say much at all on which I also have
to say it's it's one of those really
difficult things to get out of when it
comes to the way that you talk in
YouTube videos because I always notice
there's a certain way that people talk
in YouTube videos that's like sort of
very typical for them and in real life
it doesn't always carry over at least
for some of the planet coaster people I
know they just speak in such a different
way in real life than they do in videos
sometimes it's a little bit less so but
very often it still is like you kind of
tend to fall into a certain way of
speaking when you do these YouTube
videos and it's really hard to get out
of that so sometimes I'm just kind of
like you know do I speak too quickly
should I have more silences in my
commentary or is it in any way too
meandering so honestly if you
think anything if you have time any kind
of opinion no matter how harsh or
critical it might be of the way I do my
commentaries is honestly just drop it in
there because I'm always looking for any
way to improve my videos but I feel like
commentary is one of the most difficult
things to improve ever because it's an
unscripted thing you know sure this was
a sort of scripted thing it'd be much
easier to tackle them but because it's
so unscripted it's just kind of what you
naturally gravitate toward I feel like
it's something that's really difficult
to improve and kind of takes a very
conscious efforts to work on
in any case back to the topic at hand a
little bit more I think there's also a
bit of a relationship between how
important a certain part of the island
is in terms of how much of the the
overall look of the island it makes out
and how much I wanted to light it up so
the top spire is really bright and some
of the domes as well some of those top
cublas they're super bright and then
just the general walls of the buildings
I just put some spotlights on most of
those from a quite a distance often as
well so that they're slightly lit up and
you can kind of see them and it looks
atmospheric but it doesn't really draw
the attention like the spires and towers
do now something that is completely out
of line and that I sort of came up with
on the spot which you can see me doing
all over the place just like I did over
there is adding these round sort of
spherical lights everywhere I could it
isn't really something that I was
planning to do in the beginning but I
very quickly realized that there were
just some spots where I couldn't really
hide spotlights too well or put other
lights that fit in and that round
spherical light actually just looks
amazingly steampunk so I ended up
putting that in a lot of places
especially little decorations and the
lamps themselves kind of function as
part of the decoration I think because
they fit so well into the steampunk feel
of the of the entire island that you
know in daytime and at nighttime they
still kind of work as a decoration but
they also light up the areas which are
very hard to light up other
so you'll see a lot of those little
whites balls everywhere functioning as
lights throughout the island oh and
here's a little break from the rest of
the video I guess in there was still
these two spires that were using the
in-game roof spires and you know that
one do this is a silver ant build I'm
not going to use any of the ingame roof
pieces obviously if we can use hundreds
of small tiny little pieces that will
destroy the game so the letter is what I
wanted to do in the end and I finally
got around to changing these two spires
and to be honest I'm not really even
changing them too much it's honestly
just about the idea of being able to
notice that the spires were an in-game
roof piece that just kind of takes me
out of the immersion of the theme of the
island itself that I just wanted to
replace it with something very similar
looking but very unique so I wanted to
sort of make my own spire that looks
really similar but isn't quite the same
and there's a bit of an advantage to it
as well I think in that obviously it now
matches a little bit more some of the
textures which I used on other spires as
well and it's a bit more narrow it's a
bit thinner I kind of like my spires to
be really tall really kind of stretched
out and pointy in an almost efteling
kind of sense so yeah that was basically
that little break from the rest of the
video I think these kinds of spires are
also interesting because they they have
a more clear demarcation between the
different angles of the of the roof
which is kind of an accident anyway
because I need to put all of those
wooden Brown planks or beams really
between all the different segments to
make sure that the shingles that flip
into each other but it's something that
I do like the look up
and this is the kind of thing which I
also think it would be really
interesting to see how the theme makers
toolkit is gonna affect the game and
that is obviously also one of the
reasons that I am trying to hurry up and
finish these projects and perhaps also
some of my other stuff because I really
feel like the theme makers toolkit might
be too much of a game changer to still
have projects like these running because
I'd rather just finish for vara and have
it stand as a project of just trying to
push the in-game pieces as much as
possible and get as far away from any
recognizable in-game theme with them as
I can because that's kind of been the
exercise and I feel like as soon as the
theme makers toolkit comes out and you
can just import any piece into the game
and so to create any atmosphere on your
own that just kind of defeats the the
whole exercise of Favara which was so
much about just you know doing
ridiculous things with the in-game items
I mean this thing was started over a
year ago and back then so many of the
pieces which we which we now have in
which I'm now using in the island
weren't even there yet so I had to
really force my way into this sort of
steampunk theme at the beginning and I
feel that that whole idea of seeing the
game almost as a puzzle of trying to
create new things under the pieces that
were given I think that was a a major
part in what made for Varro so much fun
for me and what would be totally
destroyed if we can add anything we want
into the game ourselves so yeah I'd like
to finish it before that time and just
leave it completely vanilla if that
would be able if that would be a way to
speak about these things also some of
the other stuff that isn't lighting
related I still had the in-game catwalks
on the lift Hill over here and I'm not
really a big thing a big fan of anything
in games so I decided to get rid of
those things as well replace them with
Oh an adjusted version really of the
in-game catwalks so keeping the basic
skeleton there but replacing it with a
slightly thicker
because I like it thick things where I
can actually put some rhymes and other
shenanigans on it as well just looks a
bit fancier and it fits in a little bit
better with some of the wooden
constructions that the lift halls built
on as well I just love it when roller
coasters have that sort of like custom
supports work it's something that you
rarely see because there's so much
engineering trouble and you know making
coasters like Baron 1898 and alpengeist
where they have those custom sort of
lift Hill constructions is very
difficult but it it really just pays off
so nicely I think it gives it so much
plan obviously I'm using some supports
also because there's no other way so on
the other side of the island there some
tracks they're just kind of floating
above the ground so I obviously had to
build some custom supports so they
wouldn't end up going straight to the
ground in a vertical line and destroying
the whole idea of a floating island but
in this case I really just wanted to
signify the lift Hill with a very sort
of well signature looking lift Hill
structure oh and I wanted to light that
up with these lights as well I was
thinking for a while maybe that's too
cheesy like it almost looks like a
Christmas decoration in a way but I just
really like how it outlines the lift
Hill structure at night and I definitely
don't want to overdo the lights either
they're just on this side and they're
just following the very basic contours
of the lift Hill but it's still
something which i think is a fun little
lighting addition the lighting is pretty
much done at this point there are some
things we just still need to fix about
this park there's still some floating
trees and like little unfinished bits
and pieces that I just want to improve a
little bit and at that point I just
gonna add some random stuff until I feel
like it's done so next episode is
probably just gonna be really really
random even more than this time you know
I have no idea what to even talk about
but we'll see how that goes but after
that hopefully everything should be
finished and I can start working on a
nice video for this for weight
I don't know how much I explained yet
but I'm really looking forward to maybe
getting into some editing tricks to make
it look as though this is really flying
somewhere out there in the clouds and
change the whole environments from the
planet coaster environment to something
much more fantastical but that's
something for another day for now thank
you guys for watching and I hope to see
you guys next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]